[Musique]
bon j'ai pris les mesures
j'ai énormément j'ai tout pris il faut
faire le plan hockey en fait avant
d'aller plus loin il faut que je vous
explique un truc dans mon appart
il ya des choses que je suis obligée
d'avoir c'est un canapé mon bureau est
une télé le bureau et la télé c'est des
choses qui ont besoin d'électricité
donc ça va être collée à semur et le
canapé il est forcément en face de la
télé donc soit la télé je la mets là et
le canapé je les mets en position 1 soit
la télé jamais là et le canapé je le met
en position 2 le premier de la position
1 c'est que elle va bloquer les rayons
lumineux puisque c'est juste devant la
fenêtre il ya qu une seule fenêtre dans
cette pièce et en plus de ça je trouve
que quand on rentre dans le salon se
retrouver qu'un d'autres canapé c'est
pas très accueillant
donc je suis obligé de mettre le canapé
en position 2 et donc la télé evala le
bureau ivala et le canapé il va en
position 2 et c'est seulement à partir
de ça que je peux construire le reste
[Musique]
j'étais assez content de moi mais avait
quand même un je-ne-sais-quoi qui me
gênait je me dis que l'aide d'un ou
d'une pro ne serait pas de refus
et ça tombe bien il y en a une dans mes
abonnés instagram avec qui j'ai déjà
discuté
elle s'appelle clara et j en vois ma
question je sérieuse bah écoute j'ai
bien reçu ta question en voyant quelques
mesures parce que parce que j'ai une
idée
effectivement c'était une bonne idée
en fait ce qui me gênait c'était
l'absence de continuité entre la partie
télé canapé et la partie bureau l'idée
d'un double meuble télé qui fait toute
la longueur j ai pas pensé
du coup on a fait ensemble elle m'a aidé
à choisir une table basse sachant qu'une
contrainte c'était qu'on puisse lui
mettre ce genre de pied de micro et elle
m'a aussi aidé à trouver un canapé et le
tour était joué
merci clara
[Musique]
j'avais foutu toutes mes affaires un
stockage de meubles pour libérer mon
ancien appartement au plus vite du coup
déménagement c'est le quatrième
déménagement en mouvement de chez moi à
chaumont ex de chez monex a chez nous 2
de chez nous 2 au stockage du stockage h
à moi car très déménagement en douze
mois j'en peux plus et j'ai pas pu m'en
empêcher
j'ai fait le truc le plus iranien
possible à faire en arrivant dans un
nouvel endroit c'est à dire avant toute
chose y mettre son tapis
[Musique]
la télé tellement fat j'ai dû prendre un
reporter de guerre pour mêler à la
soulever je m'appelle charles dit là je
suis grand reporter pour le média brut
merci mon pote charles
[Musique]
bon visiblement j'apparais que les
problèmes de la cuisine et de se faire à
manger
petite vidéo première vidéo en fait je
vais tourner dans l'appart voit la
petite lumière ti micro et on est parti
ouais ça allait plus vite que ce que je
pensais et en même temps quand j'étais
en plein dedans c'était vraiment longue
quoi tout ça tout le l'emménagement quoi
et c'est pas fini c'est pas fini je vous
ferais je pense une ultime vidéo quand
vraiment j'aurais reçu tous les meubles
quand j'aurai peaufiner la déco ce genre
de truc quoi c'est pas forcément évident
en fait de rentrer dans un espace qui
est vide et de réussir à se l'approprier
en fait j'ai certes un pote qui me
disent mais que je sais pas comment tu
fais pour arriver à de projeter dans un
espace vide comme ça et j'ai aussi plein
de potes qui m'ont dit mec c'est trop
cool que tu as réussi à faire de cet
appart et c'est ta décor et défonce
voilà et enfin je me dis que c'est
peut-être l'occasion après cette vidéo
de vous donner quelques conseils en fait
quelques conseils là dedans puisque
c'est des choses qui moi me plaisent qui
me paraissent pas évidente mais en tout
cas assez naturel et qui apparemment ne
sont pas donc je me dis que ça peut vous
être utile et ses jeux qui sont
notamment très importante pour se sentir
bien chez soi et c'est pas évident en
fait comme feeling de se sentir bien
chez soi c'est pas facile le premier
truc dont je veux vous parler c'est que
il ya quelques années maintenant j'ai eu
un vrai déclic et ça m'a fait penser à
une de mes vidéos préférées c'est une
interview de steve jobs dans laquelle il
dit c'est vrai pour la vie et c'est
aussi vrai pour les appartements
en fait je me souviens qu'avant à une
certaine époque de ma vie quand je
rentrais dans un appart en tant que
locataire évidemment j'étais jeu
je me faisais un peu petit quoi j'avais
pas trop envie de modifier des choses
j'avais pas envie de perdre ma caution
j'avais peur de plein de choses et donc
en fait je me restreignait énormément et
pour moi genre l'espace était telle
qu'elle souvent c'était meubler l'espace
était comme ça a fallu faire avec et
donc fallait faire avec ce qu'on me
donnait et à quelques années j'ai
commencé à déconstruire un petit peu ça
et en fait quand je rentre dans un
espace dit ok qu'est ce qui me plaît
qu'est ce qui me plaît pas et qu'est ce
que je peux changer même si les meublés
en fait parce que je suis rentré dans
des apparts toujours les meubles me
plaisait pas eh ben je réfléchissais à
voir si j'avais la possibilité de virer
ses meubles là un endroit que j'avais où
j'ai des potes ou mon ancienne chambre
d'ado chez mes parents et cetera et
cetera un endroit où j'étais sûr de
pouvoir les récupérer à la fin dans le
même état des fois l'appartement menée
avec une cave
donc c'est encore plus facile et donc en
fait en faisant ça j'arrivais déjà à
sortir de l'appartement les choses qui
me plaisait pas et à garder ce qui me
plaisait et donc du coup je pouvais
remplacer les choses qui manquaient par
des choses qui me plaisait encore plus
puisque ces choses que j'avais vraiment
pleinement choisi mais en tout cas pour
moi dans surtout mes années étudiantes
etc
c'était une question de d'esthétisme et
que tout aille ensemble parce que je me
retrouve avec des apparts ont vraiment
rien n'allait ensemble quoi et je peux
comprendre ça que le proprio il a son
appartement et genre il a acheté cet
appart il le veut mettre en location se
dit bon pas si je vais le meublé et ils
chopent quelques meubles qu'il ay
quelques trucs qu'ils trouvent
et paf ça fait un meuble et tu vois mais
c'est assez rare en fait les meublés qui
sont vraiment beaux quoi et donc ça ça
vaut pour les meubles mais ça vaut pour
tout ça vaut pour jeu c'est pas un truc
qui vous déplaît dans la salle de bain
le rideau de douche ou vous n'aimez pas
le rideau de douche vous voulez plutôt
auparavant
en fait il ya plein de petits trucs qui
faut bien voir les règles de votre
contrat mais y'a plein de petits trucs
que vous pouvez changer sans être
propriétaire et sans nuire à
l'appartement mais c'est vraiment
j'insiste sur ce truc de déclic parce
que c'est vraiment une manière de penser
quoi c'est vraiment georges tron dans
cet appartement je fais ok ok donc cet
appartement me plaisait globalement ok
maintenant qu'est ce qui me plaît pas et
qu'est ce qui me plaît et qu'est ce que
je veux changer et l'idée c'est de faire
ce que vous voulez tant que vous le
rende est dans le même état par exemple
j'ai des appliques murales
il est possible que je les change que je
les améliore mais quand je repartirai
bas je remettrai les anciennes applique
mais au moins pendant que j'étais là bas
je me serais fait kiffer avec des
appliques murales que je trouve trop
belle quoi et c'est un investissement
puisque je vais les garder si tu
appliques murales pour mon prochain
appart mon deuxième conseil c'est
vraiment d'intellectualiser les choses
au maximum
alors ça marrant souvent souvent c'est
un truc con qu'on dit de pas faire genre
arrêt d'intellectualiser non là vraiment
je conseille martelly tu as lease et de
ouf
le risque c'est que vous arriviez dans
l'endroit et que je sais pas donc ce
soit il est déjà meublé soit il est pas
meublé mais qu' il ya un meuble qui se
retrouve à un endroit et que tout se
fasse en fonction de ce truc là et que
vous ayez pas choisi en fait
l'aménagement votre appart usher j'avais
un pote et bien dans sa famille il
changeait l'aménagement de leur
appartement genre tous les six mois je
crois à tous les six mois tous les un an
ils changent et l'aménagement totalement
à l'époque trouvé ça hyper cool hyper
stylé parce que ça permet de garder le
cerveau en éveil que c'est un machin
mais en fait aujourd'hui du recul je
trouve ça n'a aucun sens ça n'a aucun
sens parce qu'un bonne aménagements y en
a qu'un seul en fait un bon aménagement
qui vous ressemble et en a qu'un y a pas
le choix
en fait je dis pas forcément de prendre
un plan et c'est rare mais quand vous
intellectualiser le truc et pour
réfléchir au truc normalement il n'y a
pas le choix c'est que peut-être au
début il ya un choix qu'on peut faire si
ça ça ou alors on peut faire si ça ça
mais en fait au final quand vous
développez les deux scénarios y en a un
des deux qui apparaît évidemment comme
plus souhaitable plus agréable
qui vous ressemble plus que l'autre et
c'est une transition avec le troisième
point jeudi qui vous ressemble plus que
l'autre parce que dans se sentir chez
soi
il y à swat est hyper important de se
connaître et de connaître ses habitudes
pour faire un chez soi qui vous
ressemble je vous donne un exemple tout
bête dans l'entrée un couloir et est
souvent quand je rentre en fait j'ai
envie de citer mon reflet dans le dans
la vitre et samaa je me suis dit qu'est
ce que c'est que ça c'est moi yes désolé
je sais un espace que je ne ris pas
encore quand je rentre dans
l'appartement j'ai envie de poser mes
clés hockey dans un endroit et je me les
pose et directe en fait je sais pas
beaucoup parce que je les ai à la main
jouve le truc genre il est posé il n'y a
aucun endroit pour les poser en fait
dans l'entrée qu'est ce que je fais je
les fous par terre gelée fou par terre
parce que c'est mon habitude mon
habitude c'est ça mon habitude c'est de
poser mes clés à cet endroit là ok je
vais pas changer mes habitudes
c'est ma conception du truc c'est que la
parte doit s'habituer à mes habitudes
dans la mesure du possible dans la
mesure du possible évidemment mais donc
là pourquoi je le pose par terre mais
clés pour créer un problème j'ai un
problème mais clés sont par terre tout
le temps et ce en mettant en avant des
problèmes comme ça que je peux arriver
qu'une solution est là la solution c'est
simple c'est d'avoir un petit meuble qui
fasse sur lequel je me fais un vide
poche dans le couloir voilà donc il faut
que je m'en occupe
faut que je fasse ça donc c'est un peu
chez vous je ne sais pas il ya peut-être
des gens qui vous regardent ça qui est
un ami il est tard et le type mais ça me
paraît juste plus naturel de garder mes
habitudes
et si je peux faire quelques ajustements
dans l'appartement pour conserver mes
habitudes mais que ce soit plus naturel
pour moi
bah je me sentirai forcément mieux donc
ça c'est un truc pour lequel c'est
important de se connaître c'est à dire
vos automatismes vous habitudes
l'autre truc est important c'est vos
goûts en fait en termes de couleurs de
choses qui vous fait qui fait des choses
qui vous rappellent des voyages des
souvenirs des gens des événements
bref y'a il ya plein de trucs je pense
dans votre histoire en fait que que vous
voulez mettre en avant ça peut être
aussi des fictions des fictions qui vous
tiennent à coeur ça peut être des
valeurs aussi des choses qui pour vous
symbolise une valve a donc en fait
n'importe quoi qui pour vous est
important
j'avoue je trouve ça bien de le mettre
en avant et de lui donner une forme un
truc concret
moi ça se traduit dans ma bibliothèque
par des petits objets etc
mais ça peut être un truc affichés au
mur ça peut être après encore une fois
c'est très personnel mais dans ce truc
de comment se sentir bien chez soi
sauf que tout de suite ça permet de
raisonner dans l'espace pour moi c'était
les trois conseils plus important c'est
à dire avoir ce déclic de j'ai un impact
sur l'espace autour de moi et je peux le
changer
je suis pas obligé de le prendre tel
quel je peux me débrouiller même si les
meublés et ceara je peux me démerder
intellectualiser les choses faire des
choix tout doit avoir une raison se
connaître soi-même que ce soit au niveau
des habitudes ou soit au niveau des
goûts c'étaient les trucs les plus
importants pour moi en termes de comment
être bien chez soi je vais pas vous
parler de mettre des plantes essayer
d'augmenter la luminosité fluidifier les
passages entre les espaces tellement
parce que mon appart pas celui d'avant
mais celui encore d'avant il est 13
mètres carrés 13 mètres carrés
là je vous montrais deux images celle
appart globalement c'est la parte je
tournais l'attend c'était champ
contrechamp et vous avez là partent quoi
en gros en gros donc je vous parle de
fluidifier l'espace mais même dans un 13
mètres carrés on peut fluidifier
l'espace j'ai vécu mon temps dedans et
d'ailleurs ses conseils la dent le 13
mètres carrés et je les appliquaient
déjà est d'ailleurs le propriétaire avec
qui je m'entends très bien depuis et qui
regarde sûrement cette vidéo je pense
qu'il se doute pas que il est certains
meubles que j'avais enlevé et que j'ai
remis parce que pour me réapproprier
l'espace et il était très content j'ai
eu aucun preuve de caution tout était en
parfait état
j'ai restituer l'appartement comme je
les trouvais donc allez-y quoi
évidemment toujours dans le respect de
la propriété privée quoi ça reste un
bien qui n'est pas à moi ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'est pas incompatibles
on peut qui fait un endroit ce vraiment
le l'approprier sans pour autant nuire à
la personne à qui il appartient donc
voilà je rends pas sur ses conseils de
file défier l'espace plantes lumière etc
machin est ce que je pense qu'ils se
trouvent y perd facilement ce n'était
pas le but de cette vidéo là à la passe
et pas un sujet que je voulais faire sur
comment se sentir bien chez soi etc
mais j'ai montré le début de la vidéo
donc les quatre premières minutes sur
twitch et on m'a dit ouais bah mec parle
de comment se sentir bien chez soi et
tout ça peut être hyper intéressant donc
donc voilà j'espère que ça vous a plu du
coup et si ça vous n'êtes pas plus à
cause des gens sur twitter en stage j'ai
été extrêmement touché par tous vos
commentaires sur la dernière vidéo et
tous les messages que j'ai reçus de
manière générale j'ai beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de chance de vous avoir en fait
d'avoir une communauté
quand traversa le fait d'avoir une
communauté d'avoir des gens comme ça à
qui je veux je veux parler qui on
échange des choses c'est hyper c'est
hyper fort donc je suis conscient sachez
que voilà je suis conscient de cette
chance que je vous en remercie et que je
suis voilà j'ai une énorme gratitude
voilà sachez le je le ressens je sais
aussi évidemment que c'est bien plus dur
pour plein d'autres personnes qui vivent
des choses encore plus compliquées même
dans le même cadre d une rupture etc
mais qui met beaucoup plus de temps à
trouver un appart qui ont en plus
d'autres problèmes apparemment des
problèmes financiers
le problème de santé etc
je touche du bois j'ai pas eu ça donc
voilà si vous faites partie de ces
personnes nous envoie tout mon soutien
et j'espère que tout va s'arranger le
plus vite possible
voilà on se trouve on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour une vidéo qui
n'aura rien à voir avec l'emménagement
tout ça et ces appareils de totalement
autre chose
la vidéo si d'après on va parler
tellement d'autres choses et peut-être
que je reparlerai de l'appartement parce
qu'il aurait avancé j'espère j'espère
j'aurai fini la semaine a encore d'après
m et attend c'est à dire qu'il y aura
une vidéo toutes les semaines ouais je
crois que ça ressemble à ça parce que je
chante je viens de m'engager
peut-être merci beaucoup
love peace ciao